a polite handshake and the US and
Chinese delegations part ways talks in
Washington and it without agreement
after President Trump had upped the ante
in an escalating dispute over trade
Trump was bullish on a favorable outcome
no need to rush he tweeted after
slapping at 25% tariff on a further 200
billion dollars on imports a total of
twenty fifty billion dollars worth of
Chinese goods are now subject to the
tariff the levy is a sharp hike from the
previous 10% import tax so a heavy blow
for China's export oriented economy
Beijing is alarmed and called for a
compromise we hope the US and China can
meet halfway and respect the legitimate
interests of both sides
Chinese vice premier Liu he and US
Treasury secretary Steve Minuten had the
negotiation teams the u.s. is concerned
about a ballooning trade deficit and
accuses China of blocking access to his
markets it is not clear when the two
parties will meet again Trump took to
Twitter to dispel worries about a
looming trade war the income from levies
on Chinese goods will be used to prop up
ailing sectors of the economy
he promised well let's get more Amish
from DW business correspondent Janelle
Duma law and in Washington we have
Oliver Salas welcome both let's start
with you Oliver today's talks are ended
not long after they began what happened
well those were really brief talks in
fact that's right and it did not come as
a surprise though if you take into
consideration that the talks were
actually stalled a week ago already and
negotiators were not very optimistic
when they went into the talks this
morning they then went on to the White
House including the Secretary of
Treasury venusian to discuss the outcome
with US President Donald Trump who by
the way makes a very Content impression
he's been tweeting all morning long he
says essentially that tears are good for
the US economy and he also continuously
tweeted and stressed that the Chinese
would be paying for the tariffs
eventually economists however are
challenging that they believe that the
American businesses that would have to
pay the bill in the end of the day and
that they would also give that passed
that on to the consumers when for
instance consumer electronics would
become more expensive that said all
goods that are currently in transit say
they they had left the Chinese coast on
a container ship for instance and that
would take three to four weeks to arrive
in America these goods are excluded and
that gives the negotiators a certain
time frame again to renegotiate should
they get together within that time frame
okay so general the duma law china says
it will respond
what's that response likely to look like
you know it hasn't said and there are a
few things china could do but they all
come with a cost now it could for
example extend the tariffs it already
has on China on US products or return
barriers that it had already earlier
reverse they like on US auto imports the
problem is that China exports more than
the US does and it would very quickly
run out of UX US products who impose
tariffs on if it includes semiconductors
and Boeing planes alternative suppliers
for those things would also be in a
position to raise prices dramatically so
Beijing could lose out on that and what
it could also do is the value its
currency to make its exports cheaper but
that's unlikely to go over well
domestically again alternatively it
could also respond with a boycott of
American goods the problem is that a lot
of Chinese workers do work in the
assembly and manufacture of American
goods like iPhone so that could backfire
as well so it's wide open what China
could do at this particular moment but
you have quite a few analysts saying
that from an economic standpoint and
from with the perspective that what they
actually want to do is achieve a deal
the most prudent thing to do would be
nothing now this would obviously have
already occurred to Chinese policy
makers but they're also under political
pressure to act so we're just going to
have to see which side wins of that
argument okay so
Oliver salad it just bounces through the
main sticking points Oliver
so reportedly there is a debate going on
in the Chinese Communist Party about
within reformers and and hardliners
about the question how to move on here
and that led to a very late decision of
the Chinese President Xi Jinping over
the question how to tackle the ongoing
debate the key sticking points here are
the protection of intellectual property
America and one of course and also
certain laws restraining American
businesses and eventually the clash
erupted them over the question which
part of the final agreement should be
made public essentially the Chinese side
does not want to publicly admit that its
electoral property laws are flawed
because that would also mean that they
would look as the losers of this of this
trade agreement all of a solid in
Washington as you know do Malone from DW
business thank you both